字幕: Rychelle Brittain
校正: Moe Shoji
皆さんは街でアンケート調査の依頼を
されたことがあるでしょうか？
今回はそのような依頼をされたと
思ってください
そして調査の紙を渡されて
「ペンはこちらの５本から選んでください」と
言われたとしましょう
では 皆さんは
どのペンを選びますか？
今 ぜひカメラ越しの皆さんも
考えてみてください
会場の皆さんも ぜひちょっと
考えてみていただきたいんですけど
せっかくですので
ぜひ手を挙げていただきたいんですね
カメラ越しの皆さんも一緒に
手を挙げていただきたいんですが
ここでは単純に 青か赤かで
手を挙げていただきたいと思います
では 私だったら
青のペンを選ぶという方？
はい ありがとうございます
私だったら赤のペンを選ぶという方？
はい 会場は大体半々
赤がちょっと多いぐらいでした
今 早速 ちょっと言うのを
忘れてましたけど
これらは 実はすべて
黒のボールペンです
ただ柄の色が異なるだけなので
例えば 赤で答えた場合
イマイチかなとか
そういうのが
今 働いたかもしれませんけど
実際 全部黒のボールペンで
柄だけが違うという場合です
もちろん 理由を尋ねると
例えば 「左側のペンがよかったから」とか
「真ん中のペンがよかったから」とか
「私はドラゴンズファンだから青」とか
色々答えはあると思うんですね
ここで注目したいのは
青が２本 赤が３本といった形で
青のペンが少ない点です
ここでは少ない数のペンを
「ユニークなペン」と定義します
では そのようなペンを果たして
どれくらいの人が選ぶのでしょうか？
実は これは1999年に
ある実験が行われておりまして
その結果を 今ご紹介していきますと
アメリカ人と東アジア人が
今お尋ねしたような
こういう状況に置かれたんですね
そうしたところ
アメリカ人の71％が
ユニークなペンを選びました
一方でアジア人は たった15％しか
ユニークなペンを選びませんでした
個人を重視するのか
それとも関係や集団を重視するのか
それに関しては 実は
かなり大きな文化差があることが
知られています
このペン選択の結果は
何を示しているかというと
その個人の重視というのが
いかに自分と他人というのを比べて
自分がユニークなものであるか
そのユニークさを重視する心と
関連していることを示しています
一方で 関係や集団の重視というのは
周りを気にする調和を重視する心に
関連していると言われます
でも 今そのように
私は説明しましたが
おそらく皆さんは
このようなことを聞くと
「いやいや 最近の日本人は
特に若者であれば
もっとユニークなペンを選ぶのでは」と
思うかもしれません
以前であれば
「出る杭は打たれる」という言葉が
あったように
「他の人と違うことをしてしまうと
何かあんまり良くないな」というので
「ここは多数派のペンを選んでおこう」
というのがあったと思うんですね
しかし だいたい20年くらい前でしょうか
『世界に一つだけの花』という
SMAPの曲が流行りましたよね
そのあたりから教育現場でも
「個性が重要である」というのが
主張されてきました
このような感じで
私たちの心のあり方というのが変化して
もしかしたらユニークなペンを
選ぶようになる
そういうことは
考えられるかもしれません
私は社会心理学者なんですけど
その関心というのは
社会や文化の日常的な慣習が
いかに心の性質に影響を与えるのかって
いうところにあります
実は そういったような影響というのは
皆さんが意識していないところで
生じるもので
気づかないものなのですね
ですから社会心理学者は
実験をやる際 その参加者には
目的がわからないような形で
テストをします
今のペン選択のテストも
私が 今このように
種明かしをしなければ
おそらく皆さんは その本当の目的に
気づくことはなかったと思います
このペン選択のテストは
単純でわかりやすいのですが
異なったテストを用いて
本当に日本人は
調和のとれたものを好むのか
それともユニークなものを好むのか
そしてペン選択では 実は
明らかになっていない点なんですが
日本人は調和の取れたものを
生み出しやすいのか
それともユニークなものを
そういった点を明らかに
していくことは重要です
そこで私が何をやったかというと
幾何学図形に対する塗り絵ですね
そういうのに着目しました
ここでは幾何学図形を
いろいろ用意して
さまざまな幾何学図形を
日米の大学生に見せまして
日米の大学生が
「好きなように色を塗ってください」
っていうふうに
そのテストでは尋ねられました
あくまでも 今皆さんが見てるのは
その一例なんですけど
左と右 どちらが日本人の
学生のものかわかりますか？
おそらく直感でわかると思うんですけど
実はこれは同じ色えんぴつのセットを
使ってんですけど
ずいぶん違いますよね
ちなみに正解は右が
日本人の学生の塗り絵です
左がアメリカ人の学生の
塗り絵なんですが
このアメリカ人の塗り絵というのは
勝手に線を引いたり
また色をめちゃくちゃ濃く塗ってますよね
そういったところからも
ユニークな塗り絵が多かったんです
この日本人の塗り絵というのは
まず枠を線で囲んで
その中をきれいに塗ったりとか
調和のとれた色使いをしたりする
やっぱり調和を重視した
塗り絵というのが多くなってました
次に このように集めた塗り絵を
日米のものを１つの組にして
また今度は別の日米の大学生に見せて
どちらが好きかというのを
二者択一で尋ねました
二者択一ですから
回答パターンとしては
ランダムにやったら
50％になります
もちろん 好みを判断してもらう
好みのテストの際には
その参加者には
これが誰の塗り絵であるか
誰が生み出したか
日本人の塗り絵とか
アメリカ人の塗り絵とか
そういったようなことは
一切伝えませんでした
だから 参加者は
そういったようなことを知らずに
好みのテストをやったというわけです
その結果をご紹介していきましょう
どういう結果になったかというと
95組 実は塗り絵があったんですね
そのうち日本人参加者は
日本人の塗り絵を好んだのは
57％でした
一方 アメリカ人の塗り絵を
好んだのが43％でした
一方 アメリカ人参加者は
そのうち日本の塗り絵を
好んだのは47％でした
一方でアメリカ人の塗り絵を
好んだのは53％でした
見ていただければ わかる通り
かなりグラフのパターンが
逆になってるってことが
わかっていただけるかと思います
今回のこういう結果というのは
もちろん異なった参加者を
対象にして同じテストをやっても
同じような結果が
見いだされることがわかってます
また塗り絵というのは 実は子どもを
対象にしてもやることが可能です
そのことによって
こういった文化差っていうのが
どういった つまり発達の中で
何歳ごろに出てくるのか
そういうのを見ることが可能です
実際 日本とカナダの
４歳から６歳の子どもたちに対して
同じように「好きなように
色を塗ってください」ということで
塗り絵をやってもらったんですね
そうした結果を見てみますと
先程ご紹介した
日米の大学生の塗り絵のパターン
ユニークさなのか
その調和のとれた塗り絵なのか
そういった文化差がやはり
その子どもたちの塗り絵でも出てきました
さらに私たちの追加の調査では
そういった子どもの塗り絵に対する
親の反応に関しても
文化差がありました
カナダ人の親は
そうした子どもの塗り絵を見て
ユニークさを促すような反応ですね
そういうのを好みました
例えば「自由に色を塗りなさい」
そういったような反応
そういったものを好みました
一方 日本人の親は
どうだったかというと
やはり調和を促すような反応
「枠に沿って色を塗りなさい」
そういう反応を好みました
では 最初の方で私が言ったことを
思い出していただきたいんですが
日本人であれば
特に若者であれば
ユニークなペンを選ぶのではないか
そういう投げかけをしました
皆さんもご存知の通り
グローバル化が進んで
インターネットのおかげで
今 世界中どこの情報でも
知ることができます
ということは世界中の人々が
接する情報というのは
かなり同じようなものになっています
グローバル化というのは一般的に
個人主義化を促すということが
言われています
ですから 早い話
世界中がユニークなペンを選ぶようになる
これがひとつの可能性なんですね
しかし 今日ご紹介した研究からも
わかる通り
その可能性っていうのは
あまりないでしょう
社会や文化の変化に応じて
私たちの心の性質というのも
確かに変化はしていくのですが
その変化のスピードというのは
緩やかなものです
このことは 変化を
求めるような人たちからしてみたら
意外な結論かもしれないんですけど
人の心はそんなに簡単に変わらない
これが今日のメッセージになります
とはいえ そういった変化を
求める人たちからしてみたら意外な結論
もしかしたら皆さんから見ても
意外な結論かもしれませんが
［人と社会・文化の相互構成］
人とその人が生きる社会文化というのは
お互いがお互いを作り合ってる
そういう風なものになってる
その理解については
ぜひ注目してください
今日の話というのは
まず文化差から明らかなように
私たちというのは何もない状況の中で
生きているわけでは決してありません
そして文化の中で優勢な価値観
例えば ユニークさとか
調和といったものがありましたが
そういった価値観に合った
そういうのを含んだ塗り絵をつい描いてしまう
また そういった価値観を含んだ
塗り絵をつい好んでしまう
さらにはその価値観を親世代から
子世代へとつい伝えてしまう
こういったようなことからも
わかる通り
私たちというのは社会文化の影響を
ただ受けているわけではありません
むしろ そういったような振る舞いによって
私たちというのは
私たちが生きている社会文化を
維持させていくことになっています
よって 私たちというのは社会文化を
再生産する存在であると言えます
そして重要なことに
今私が言ったようなプロセスというのは
実は無自覚無意識のうちに
起こるものです
社会心理学者の仕事というのは
さまざまなテストを行って
そこでの反応を
分析していくことによって
まさにそういった無自覚無意識の
プロセスというのを
暴いていくことにほかなりません
この人と社会文化というのが
互いに作り合っている
そのプロセスというのを
明らかにしていくことというのは
人間とは何かに関する理解を
大きく深める上でも
さまざまな貢献があるのではないか
というふうに確信しています
ありがとうございました